we're a phenomenon attracted so many
visitors to a Southern California town
that officials declared public safety
emergency it's called the super bloom as
it's called and it has drawn tens of
thousands of people the town of Lake
Elsinore briefly cut off access to these
poppy fields on Sunday calling the
crowding unbearable Jamie yuccas
explains how this extraordinary site led
to such an ordeal for the community
Southern California's unusually wet
winter has created an explosion of color
one of mother nature's most dazzling
displays hillsides overrun with poppies
I didn't expect the flowers to be so
vibrant colorful this is probably just
the most picturesque thing that I've
ever seen my entire life but it might be
too much of a good thing for Lake
Elsinore there's been fights over
parking spaces folks trampling on the
poppies the town of about 60,000 saw
roughly a hundred thousand visitors on
Sunday
forcing Mayor Steve Munoz to declare a
poppy apocalypse we have some residents
who are not used to this type of traffic
and attention that are concerned about
you know their ability to go ahead and
operate on a daily basis it got so bad
the mayor says one of his employees was
clipped by a car and the city is now
reaching out to the county and even the
state for help they want the perfect
social media post for sure with social
media driving the poppy frenzy some
worry the Alaura of a perfect post might
be harming the star of nature's show
people sitting in the flowers for that
one picture that I know it's special to
have the picture of you with the poppies
but then you're ruining them for other
people in the future the town reopened
the site Monday saying it was not
feasible for us to keep visitors away
though they noted access and parking was
limited you know we've gone through
fires and floods we'll get through the
full hours he's not alone other parks in
the region are just starting to see
their flowers bloom which means poppy
mania is infectious and spreading and
for now there's no cure in sight for CBS
this morning
Jamie yuccas Los Angeles
don't you guys think the town of Lake
Elsinore is saying thanks a lot CBS this
morning oh that makes traffic was go see
it makes me want to go see you know
somebody just said it was the most
picturesque thing they've ever seen your
entire life I want to go there well
between fires and floods they'd rather
have flowers they're gonna be all right